queremos factorizar t cuadrada menos 2 t
menos 15 y seguramente más a decir que
factorizar esto es muy sencillo pero en
esta ocasión yo quiero ver la
factorización por agrupación que tampoco
es tan difícil lo único que hay que
hacer es aplicar todo lo que ya sabemos
t cuadrada menos 2 t menos 15 y lo
primero que me voy a fijar es en dos
números que multiplicados median menos
15 recuerda que nos fijamos en la
multiplicación del coeficiente que está
dado delante cuadrada y del término
libre 1 x menos 15 me da menos 15
entonces voy a buscar dos números que
multiplicados me den menos 15 ya su vez
estos mismos números cumplan que la suma
de ellos me dé menos 2 es decir este
término que tengo aquí el coeficiente
que está al lado de la t entonces a más
20 tiene que ser igual a menos 2 y bueno
para esto lo primero que quiero que veas
es que tenemos una multiplicación que
emitirían que dar de resultado un número
negativo por lo tanto uno de estos dos
valores tiene que ser positivo y el otro
tiene que ser negativo mientras que por
otra parte la suma de ellos me tienen
que dar menos 2
así que voy a agarrarme los factores del
15 para ver en qué descomposición del 15
puedo obtener dos números que me cumplan
ambas igualdades así que empecemos
tomemos el 1 y el menos 15 que es una
descomposición del 15
ambos son factores del 15 pues 1 x menos
15 me da menos 15 sin embargo cuando yo
lo sumo me va a dar 1 menos 15 es lo
mismo que menos 14 y por lo tanto que me
sirve menos 1 y 15 menos 1 y 15 me da su
suma 14 por lo tanto tampoco es menos 2
y no me sirve a ver qué pasa si tomo 3 y
53 x menos 5 me da menos 15 y 3 menos
sin comida menos 2 y qué creés estos dos
valores me cumplen mis dos ecuaciones
simultáneas por lo tanto estos son los
dos números que estoy buscando 3 y menos
5 porque 3 y menos cinco meses suman
menos 2 3 x menos 5 me da menos 15 y 3
menos 5 me da menos 2 y perfecto ya que
encuentre estos dos valores ahora lo que
voy a hacer es escribir
este trinomio que quiero factorizar de
la siguiente manera en lugar de poner
menos 2 te voy a escribir 3 de menos 5
cm así que déjame reescribir todo esto
tengo t cuadrada en primer lugar y hasta
el final tengo menos 15 y aquí en medio
tengo que escribir menos los temas pero
lo voy a escribir de la siguiente manera
me voy a escribir como más 3 te más 3
stem y después menos 5 t3 de menos 5
tema porque 3 t menos 5 tm dan menos 2 t
y este trinomio sigue intacto solamente
que ahora voy a factorizar esto por
agrupación y para ello lo primero que
necesito es tomarme la primera pareja de
de términos que tengo aquí y factorizar
lo más que se pueda y después tomarme la
siguiente pareja de términos que tengo
aquí y factorizar también lo más que se
pueda más 3 t menos 5 tm da menos 2 tema
y entonces vamos a factorizar y que me
va a quedar bueno déjenme agarrar otro
color y voy a decir que voy a factorizar
primero estos 2
y después voy a factorizar los
siguientes dos de estos dos voy a
factorizar lo más que se pueda y si te
das cuenta lo más que se puede este t
que multiplica a más tres deporte metro
cuadrado y t por más tres me da más tres
t y a continuación me voy a tomar los
siguientes dos términos que tengo aquí y
de aquí voy a actualizar lo más que se
pueda y si te das cuenta lo más que se
puede es un -5 menos 5 que multiplica a
bueno menos 5 t entre menos 5 me da t
entonces tengo que escribir tema y
después menos 15 entre menos 5 es menos
entre menos me da más 15 entre 5 a 3 y
entonces le sumó 3 perfecto ya tengo
esta expresión que tengo aquí y ahora
quiero que te des cuenta que tengo al
tema estrés como factor común tengo el
tema estrés que va a multiplicar tanto a
esta parte como a esta parte temas 3
está en ambos suman 2 por lo tanto voy a
escribir esta expresión como temas 3 que
va a multiplicar bueno en primera parte
va a multiplicar ate y después va a
multiplicar a menos 5 date cuenta que el
tema estrés es un factor común
multiplicar y asumir multiplica menos 5
entonces me quedan temas 3 que
multiplica al menos 5 y ahora cierro el
paréntesis y ya cuando esto tengo la
factorización de esta expresión fíjate
que el tema es 3 es este que está aquí y
en el siguiente paréntesis está te sale
de esta te que tengo aquí y este menos 5
sale de este menos 5 que está aquí por
lo tanto ya tengo una factorización de
esta expresión que yo tengo aquí arriba
que era de cuadrada menos 2 t menos 15
como temas 3 porte menos 5 y en esa
ocasión lo hice utilizando las mismas
propiedades de la factorización por
agrupación al final en este caso no
teníamos un número al lado de la t
cuadrada sin embargo pudimos utilizar el
mismo procedimiento para obtener esta
misma factorización nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo